[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay you guys you gotta listen to the
music
we're gonna adjust some levels okay
dallas will you sing comment
sonic go get it
the problem is the music just drowns her
out they all sing the whole time their
mics need to be up sit down for a second
what can we do to fix their situation
that's it
we need better mics here's your phone we
we have two hours so we can get mics
here we live in la these mics they're
not designed for singing they're
designed for speaking if we're doing a
ted talk these mics would be perfect
we're doing the furthest thing from a
ted talk right now so we are on a
mission to find six
good clean microphones where in two
hours
i'll let you know is there any way to
rent headset mics we can come pick them
up right now i can have someone be there
asap whatever works for you but good
high quality headsets jess is this
normal this many technical stuff when
you're on tour and everything yeah
they really really want to do this for
you they're like we're not letting just
down all right do it that's important
that we do it right though
you guys may go get water take your
jackets off take a break if we don't get
new microphones we're not performing
today
end of story
[Music]